welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down
Deadpool with the third film right
around the corner I thought we'd return
to the original to talk about how it was
made the Easter eggs in it and
everything that brought us this Comic
Book classic now Ryan Reynolds put in
maximum effort in order to get it
released with it originally looking like
it would never see the light of day you
see the film had actually been in
development since 2004 with David es gu
pening the script coming off the back of
Blade Trinity the par work together to
make well what was basically Deadpool
light but in in a way this helped to
pave the way this is why they thrown
this line later as it was supposed to be
a n to the roots of him getting the role
have fun at your midnight showing a
blade too Artis had signed a deal with
Marvel just four years earlier and they
seemingly own the rights of the
character Reynolds was down to do it and
thus the pair started putting it
together but they ran into a snag turned
out that fox owned the rights to the
X-Men and technically that encompassed
Deadpool as well sis and never got to do
it but it peaked Fox's interest and thus
I started putting their own Deadpool
plans together this included X-Men
Origins Wolverine which originally was
going to have Reynolds as a cameo
however the further they worked on the
script the more they realized he could
work as the end villain however we all
know how that turned out though they did
make sure to keep the character alive in
the post credit scene yay now even
though it leaked heavily and got
terrible reviews the film still might
Bank in the opening weekend thus a
Deadpool movie was put into production
with a SC being worked out in 2010
Robert Rodriguez said he was down to
direct but he stepped down and was
replaced by Tim Miller Miller had worked
on the VFX for the X-Men films and even
shot the opening scene for th the Dark
World his friendship with James Cameron
really helped to get the movie made and
he was pushed here to make his first
full feature length film however after
Green Lantern came out Fox [__] the bed
a bit and started working behind the
scenes to try and change the film
structure they wanted to go the PG-13
route and needed some test footage
before G liting the flick they ended up
getting Miller to produce a CGI render
which Ryan Reynolds then provided the
voice of fox said Fox this and then can
the whole idea with them instead wanting
him to feature in a teamup movie this
was around about 2012 which is when the
Avengers had just changed Cinema you get
a team up you get a team up everyone
gets a team up movie and thus they scrap
the project and work together putting
Deadpool in a team of film that is of
course until 2014 when someone someone
ended up leaking that test footage now
no one knows who this this devil is as
so far the perpetrators have never came
forward Reynolds himself said he wish
that he thought of that as in the end
it's what helped get the movie made
we'll never know never know who did it
but Reynolds was clearly thankful of the
handsome devil behind it after getting
showed with love from the fans Fox
begrudgingly decided to put it in
production and now that people had seen
the test footage it also meant that it
was going to be all rated thus Reynolds
got to make the movie he wanted even
though it did have a much smaller budget
that came in at just 58 million after
initially being 65 Fox apparently cut $7
million from the budget at the last
minute which forced their hand on a lot
of different things they ended up having
to alter the script because of this and
they removed a motorbike Chase between
Deadpool and Francis this cut down the
film's reaction scenes to just the two
so they then reworked the script to tell
things in a nonlinear Way the final
fight was also scale down which is why
Wade forget his bags of guns and ammo
God damn it going to do this your fast F
way with two
swords and maximum effort you can
actually catch this bag in the car later
on with them leaving it in the front SE
as he gets out either way I think the
scaleb stuff works in the film and they
even poke fun at Fox for being cheap
it's a big house it's funny that I only
ever see two of you it's almost like the
studio couldn't afford another X-Men
this is because they wanted a huge acman
Cameo but fox said he's going to cost
too much now that it was a bit of a dig
he's made you look a right knob this is
apparently Fox chairman James G alu's
favorite line which at least the guy
knew how to take a joke the film was
shot with a working ttle Wham with
George Michael getting several
references in the trilogy at 30 minutes
we see Wade saying his most prized
possessions his wor album and Careless
Whispers played throughout the film cut
of the announcement of Deadpool 3 and we
also had wake me up before you goo
played as the music in the very first
trailer that takes us in the film itself
but now just a quick word from our
sponsors hey this video is sponsored by
Z biotic now last time we advertised
this brand I told you a personal story
about how I believed in them so much I
actually used my own money to go out and
buy a big box because I really think
this stuff works I'm going out this
Saturday with my mates the both of them
really looking forward to it but the
first drink that I'm going to have is
one of these little bad boys that's
because I'm getting a bit older and to
be honest I don't bounce back the next
morning exactly like how I used to I can
either have a great night or a great
next day but said biotics makes it so
that isn't even a choice anymore
zbiotics is a gamechanging preal
probiotic drink that's the world's first
genetically engineered probiotic it was
invented by PhD scientist to help you
feel better the morning after drinking
now here's how it works when you drink
alcohol gets converted into a toxic
byproduct in the gut it's is byproduct
not dehydration that leaves you feeling
rough the next day in advance zbiotics
produces an enzyme and it helps to break
this byproduct down just take my advice
make Z biotics your first drink drink
responsibly and you'll have your best
tomorrow like I said I've bought this
out my own money you know we get sent
these for free but I just thought that I
had to have one myself because I really
think it works if you got kids or you
want to go to the gym or just get up out
of bed you know that drinking can often
hold you back so this really helps out
and you know Valentine's Day is right
around the corner so make sure you pair
that wine and chocolate with a bit of
zbiotics go to zbiotics
docomo or scan the QR code on screen
right now it'll give you 15% off your
first order so go to zbiotics docomo
spoilers and use the code heavy spoilers
at check out for 15% off you can also
sign up to their Subscription Service as
well so if you're planning on having a
big 2024 then these guys have got you
covered zbiotics is also backed with a
100% money back guarantee so if for for
whatever reason you're unsatisfied
they're going to refund you no questions
asked remember head to zbiotics docomo
and use the code heavy spoilers at
checkout for 15% off your first order
thank You Zed biotics for sponsoring
this video again really appreciate it
and love you guys peace if you're
starting up the DVD Blu-ray or 4K then
you're going to be hit with Chef pool
ripping up a chimmy chonga that he then
microwaves this then explodes and takes
us into some action scenes in the film
just before the final battle Deadpool
says time to make the chimmy [__]
chongas which have become his favorite
food in the franchise however Reynolds
picked this purely because of the way it
sounds as in the Comics Deadpool prefers
pancakes and the movie opens with Angel
of the Morning by Juice Newton which was
apparently the first thing they put into
the script that's according to IMDb
trivia and it also talked about the
names and the credits these were
apparently originally used as
placeholders but Tim Miller found it so
funny that he just left it in we see
it's some douchebags film produced by
ass hats and starring God's perfect
idiot this is beside Ryan Reynolds
sexiest man alive cover which he got
given by People magazine in 2010 we've
then got a hot chicken Marina bararan a
British fill in and Ed scrine a moody
teenager for Nega Sonic Stanley's
gratuitous Cameo and then Colossus is
the CGI character you also have the real
heroes being rat Rees and Paul wernick
who put in maximum effort for the film
to be ridden instantly lets you know the
tone of the movie and this intro is
filled with lots of cool Easter EGS
first see we pull out to see the guy
Deadpool later burns with a cigarette
lighter and originally he was going to
make a joke about him being Bullseye
that was in an OD to Daredevil but what
we'll talk about the complicated rights
issues in a bit from here we go to a
coffee cup with a name Robel on it which
is aned Deadpool creat a Rob life
there's also a card coming out of a
wallet which is a n to Ryan Reynolds
role is the Green Lantern as we go from
the wallet we can see there's also a
card that's come out for number five
orange this is a strip club from
Reynolds Hometown in Vancouver which is
where they go at the 1 hour 11 Mark
which I know from from the sign outside
if my wife is watching as I do not know
anything about strip cloes and if I was
Googling the address of number five
Orange it's purely because it was for
research purposes for a YouTube
video there's also a Hello Kitty lip
balm and Deadpool did a TI with Hello
Kitty to sell Hello Kitty backpacks
Hello Kitty backpacks what he loads up
with the guns at the end and this is
what he leaves behind in the taxi now we
then see way teabagging poking someone
in the eye and lastly wedging someone
before cutting to a bigger freeway shot
here we can see an x on the skyscraper
before we then C to a drawing which we
later see him sketching on the bridge
however there it says hi I'm Francis
rise here it says hi I'm Deadpool to
introduce the character this sequence is
build off the back back of the short
film Carousel which was created by Adam
Berg in 2009 Berg was apparently a front
runner to direct this film and though he
didn't get it they kept the sequence in
now from here we cut to a cabin meet do
Pinda which Reynold said was named after
a kid that he went to school with he
said that he sadly got struck by
lightning and that the character was
named as a tribute to him he told this
at a Google Talk and it was met with
some nervous laughter to which Reynold
said I'm sure that was more information
than you ever wanted to know really
random story but it acts as a tribute to
him with do his Taxi hearing throughout
the film The Sign on the top says need a
hero and we also learn that his cousin
stuffed in the boot not a boot itself
you see kids in England we sometimes
call the trunk the boot but that's more
information than you ever wanted to know
but Reynolds provided the muffled cries
that we hear coming out from
it Deadpool also introduces himself as
do pool dead which is likely ripping off
how James Bond always reverses the name
order when he's introducing ing himself
in the taxi Deadpool constantly mentions
Christmas Merry Christmas this is a
carryover from an earlier version of the
movie why the fancy dir suit Mr pool oh
that's because it's Christmas Day do
Pender and I'm after someone on my
naughty list a Jax or or rather Francis
he was going to be getting released from
the raft on Christmas day let's just say
It's Beginning to Look a Lot Like
Christmas later on in the Montage when
he hunts him down we had a deleted scene
where he was like a kid counting down
the dates to Christmas the raft was too
shown to us in a deleted scene but they
had an issue getting the rights to it
the raft of course also appeared in
Civil War which Marvel released in
2016 thus they didn't want to risk the
lawsuit the Disney snipers which
happened with a number of other things
that included Bob who we meet around the
hour 30 Mark
Bob wait Bob here is a nod to Bob agent
of Hydra who's a side character that
appears throughout Deadpool comics
however they had to remove the Hydra
element in case it caused to potential
lawsuit with a studio this was also seen
in Deadpool's mask as well where there
being a joke about how it was an inside
out Spider-Man one last see though the
finale seems to feature a hle carrier
they spent time making sure it was
altered enough to not cause issues they
also wanted a cameo with nicholus hole
which was going to build off the back of
this line help Beast to stop [__] on
my lawn and you we were then going to
cut to hold dropping a steaming pile of
[__] in his garden but unfortunately H
didn't have the schedule to allow it
after meeting Ajax at the airport we
watch as he heads out in his Convoy
which Deadpool later intercepts on the
freeway Ed SC had he basis on RB from
Blade Runner with them also adding in a
touch of real life serial killer Harold
Shipman jumping over to that this scene
is obviously a recreation of the test
footage they put together they rid it
from the ground up though and altered a
couple of things again due to all the
rights originally Deadpool was playing
holl Back Girl by Gwen Stefani but this
was then changed to Salt and Pepper sh
Fox requested that the song got used but
apparently there was a hold up with
right's Team pep called salt and they
were apparently pissed cuz Deadpool's
their favorite superhero eventually
cleared though were their kids' Minds
being blown when they saw Ryan wrapping
it on the bridge here he says whose
balls did I have to fondle to get my
very own movie I can't tell you but it
does rhyme with pine this is our first
nod to Hubert Jackman and behind the
scenes he apparently used his name in
the franchise to help this get greenlit
the pair are of course great mates and
yeah I can't wait to see them in the
third film together as we cut to the
bridge we can see a sign that says Oro
Road and birdie Parkway with the first
being a reference to Thomas oo who
worked on the visual effects as Ajax
drives on the motorbike right after this
pay attention because you can see him
past a sign that says lifel Street and
Kelly way with the first obviously being
his creator and the second being a n
rider Joe Kelly who worked on the book
in 97 we then see Ajax passing under
signs on a bridge ditco can be seen here
in a odd to the legendary artist Steve
ditco who is of course one of the
forefathers of Marvel next to that we
can also see mcginness and w with
mcginness being an artist whereas werick
is a screenwriter he help produce his
film and we then get this line rich
Corinthian leather which is a nod to
this request nothing beyond the thickly
cushion luxury of seats available even
in soft Corinthian leather now as
Deadpool's head is smash like the like
button we also get a sample of the 1966
Batman
show as he kicks the guy out we can also
see silver Ren Grayson Circle which I'm
not too sure on though the ladder might
be di grayon I don't know why it would
be that but it's nice having to pause
the film every two seconds to read this
stuff and thank God I didn't make my
parents Proud by getting an actual job
anyway we then cut to the opening
credits played out at normal speed with
Deadpool taking down the bad guys as one
of the guys is beheaded we can see a
sign that says Shaham road which is a
nod to toar Shaham who worked on the
visual effects the Swagger drive and
Tristan a but I can't find anyone for
them and I'm not that smart so if you
know then drop it below C to the final
street sign shot and we can see Parker
which is an not to P the Parker and
Lassie Nizza the letter of which is
Fabian Nizza who wrote the first
Deadpool solo Series in
1993 that also just happens to be the
air ship was released and as I've been
saying it's all connected now if you
want to support the channel we're
selling its all connected t-shirts right
below the video we also got our Theory
Time stuff House of dragon and more and
huge thank you to everyone who picks one
up jumping across to the X mansion we
get a returning location from the
franchise we we often get to hang out
out when it's not getting blown up every
other film this of course appeared in
the original X-Men films and was later
used in the DC show Arrow we see the
sign for the address outside of it which
I believe was repurposed from the
original X-Men film inside we can catch
Colossus eating serial and this is a
location that showed up in X2 this is
where Wolverine and Iceman hung out
which then led into the attack by
William Striker this attack then led
into Colossus upstairs which was his
first liveaction appearance in his metal
form here we also meet negga Sonic
teenage Warhead who was named after a
song by Monster Magnet she was
originally going to be the character
Cannonball but they switched it off
because they liked her name better what
the [__] that's the coolest name ever
now for the film they ended up changing
her abilities with her originally being
a telepath however the writers thought
that didn't fit with a name so instead
switched things up and gave her the
explosive Powers at about 37 minutes
Deadpool asks if she's a sidekick but
instead they say she's a trainee so what
you're like uh he sidekick no TR this
was apparently because Stanley hated
Sidekicks so Marvel movies had a mandate
to steer clear of using that on the
bridge we then see him shooting people
as he counts down the bullets lying down
they used a similar pose of him on a
bare skin rug for lots of the movie's
promotion this in itself is an OD
Reynolds who did a nude photo shoot on
top of one killing the henchmen he then
switches to slicing people up with his
katas in order to take down a mutant
that survives the head shot this is Ryan
reyolds stunt double from Blade Trinity
which is a nice way to pay him back for
for being in that movie these swords are
put into his back to be in the next
formation and the name both being an
author this is theard to Golden Girl
star beur who Deadpool was a big fan of
in the comics in the next scene we catch
him dealing with a pizza guy and also
sees wearing a t-shirt with her face on
the front according to Reynolds the
rights of that cost $110,000 but in the
end it was donated a charity after
getting shot in the butthole we then get
what's one of my favorite Cuts in cinema
history up there with the bounded
satellite shot in 2001 and we cut from
the butt shot into another butt shout
out to the Canadian lad for pointing out
you can actually catch the guy who shot
Deadpool sneaking up in the wing mirrror
of the car which is such a cool detail
this takes us into the pizza scene and
the boxes have the words Fig's famous in
a not to Kevin figy this pizza scene was
put in as a direct nod to issue 10 of
the 2008 run with a dialogue and shock
composition being almost identical I
love how he then jumped him in the
street with sunglasses showing that he
stole them from the guy in the prior
scene turns out he's protecting a girl
named Megan which shows he he's a bad
guy but he's got a heart of gold
probably always subscribes and the
YouTubers he subscribes to they they
love them so much they give them
discounts even when they're buying
Blu-rays right now we've teamed up with
arrow films who sell lots of 4K Classics
like Robocop and they've just launched
carry if you want 10% off just head to
our Link in the description and use the
code heavy spoilers at checkout shabo
now from here we could have the sister
Margaret's bar away with girls this
mercenary bar is the player Xavier's
School for gifted youngsters with it
also containing a cameo from Creator Rob
lield lield we then get these lines at
the bar playing off Xmen Origins which
in itself was referenced a full metal
jacket it's traveling to exotic places
Baghdad madesu Jacksonville meeting new
and exciting
people all I ever wanted was to travel
the world exotic places meet new and
exciting
people and then kill them killing them
yeah I've seen your Instagram so I
wanted to see exotic Vietnam the jewel
of Southeast
Asia I uh I wanted to meet interesting
and stimulating people of an ancient
culture and kill them after starting a
ball fight by buying Buck a quote
unquote [__] from another dude we see
a Deadpool on the wall this has got the
names of the following on it Bill Cosby
Charlie Sheen Kanye West Wade Wilson
Vladimir Putin Jay Booth Ryan Reynolds
TJ Miller obviously very fourth wall
breaking there Lindsay Lohan Miley Cyrus
krock Mike Tyson Jay Nelson Little Wayne
shy La boof Ned baty Rob leld Aussie
Osborne and Amanda bines struggling to
read that with my bad eyesight and
originally Amy wein house's name was
going to be on this board and there was
going to be a running jug throughout the
entire movie this script can be read on
internet archive with a singer's name
being mentioned six times throughout he
would see his getting cutaway scenes in
which he almost died that will lace
throughout the movie then for the post
credit scene we'd see her get run over
by a double decker bus with a body
getting spray over trafala Square sadly
she died in 2011 and thus they removed
it due to it being distasteful now from
this point we then meet Vanessa who's a
character that comes from the comics in
that she was also a prostitute but
bararan ended up wanting to flesh out
the role in the comics she ends her
becoming copycat who's a Mystic type
mutant with a power to shape shift
Olivia mun was originally in the par but
she backed out in order to play psylock
both this and apocalypse were produced
by Simon kinberg with a audition here
helping to open up that door anyway this
whole scene of them going back and forth
is a reference to Monty Python's for
yorkman skit of childhood rougher than
yours Daddy left before I was born daddy
left before I was conceived we used to
live in a tiny Tumbl down old house with
great hes in roof house you look at have
house we used to live in one room 26 of
us all there no furniture half the floor
was was missing and we were all lled in
one corner for fear of
falling room you will look it to have a
room we used to have to Liv in Corridor
I watched my own birthday party Through
the Keyhole of a locked closet which
also happens to be my your bedroom lucky
I slept in a dishwasher box you had a
dishwasher John CLE is of course a
founding member with his Faulty Towers
car getting a reference later on is it
basil 4y montypython were also given an
odd when Deadpool fights Colossus with
it riffing off the back of the the Black
Knight sketch I promise this gets worse
for you big boy this is
embarrassing all right we call it a draw
this includes ND to Robo Cop Dead or
Alive you're coming with me dead or
alive you are coming with me and
Reynolds is home in Canada with the
Canadian national anthem
Canada pool also does what some animals
do when trapped and he cuts off his limb
in order to escape during this he says
are you there be God it's me Margaret
this is a reference to a novel by Judy
Bloom which is about a girl getting her
first period match that with the blood
spray and you you get that mate you get
that anyway we cut to a fake outshot of
Vanessa and Wade having sex which is
revealed to be at an arcade cashing in
his tickets we can also see a dog up on
the top shelf with a red mask and black
eyes this is a not to dog pool who we
know is going to be appearing in
Deadpool 3 because Ryan Reynolds posted
about it on Instagram spoiler alert
during the love Montage scene we see
them sitting about reading with way
diving into the Memoirs of Mario Lopez
this is a reference to their April
Fool's video in which they announced the
movie would be all right H and I heard
the uh the movie studio just announced
that they're aiming for a PG-13 rating
yeah we're working to I mean yeah we're
working to keep the spirit of the comic
book alive though I think it's smart man
that you guys keep it uh family friendly
because yeah I don't know if I'd go you
know so so far as to say it's you know
family friendly but bottom line Ryan
there may a billion reasons to make a
familyfriendly movie as in sequels and
toys and and and listen Ryan
if you Slater April fools Deadpool will
of course be rated R way all sends are
posing with a ring pop which was a bit
of a meme at the time but it took off
later during the pandemic when couples
couldn't really leave the house Vanessa
then says ride a [__] back like yod
on Luke which he signifies his Empire
and way then
says Jesus Christ it's like I made you
in a computer and this is a OD to weird
signs you get that mate now getting his
cancer diagnosis makes him realize how
much he loves hair and it's in this he
sees how much he's going to lose we then
cut back to the highway and get more of
a focus on the X before Deadpool then
kicks the crap out of Francis that's why
Regina rhymes with fun now this is a
saying that became famous after MC
Jagger used it to describe the town
during a concert this was originally
where the motorbike Chase was going to
go down out with the budget then making
them reduce it to what we get we then
get this line yeah like I got bit by a
radioactive sharpi obviously obviously
mate this is a reference to Spider-Man
who who got bitten by a radioactive
spider however the sharp itself comes
from Deadpool comics when he said he
looked like Ryan Reynolds cross with a
sharp this has since made Reynolds think
he was destined to play the role and we
then get a call back to his own previous
iteration that happens when Colossus
throws Deadpool and we then cut to a
figure from XMen Arin I think we can all
agree that [__] just went sideways in
the most colossal way well maybe not the
most this is obviously a n to Colossus
but also how much that movie now he
[__] everything up back with Vanessa
we see two Broadway references with Wade
wearing a shirt for rent Vanessa also
holds up a purse with Bernard at Peters
on it who starred in several Broadway
shows Bren has the character Roger dying
from HIV with it being a prolonged
illness that was picked in marow White's
cancer we were originally going to get
several scenes of him seeking out
treatment that would see him going
across the globe there's a deleted scene
of him going out to Mexico where there
apparently a miracle clinic this is said
to feature a doctor who performs psychic
surgery but Wade quickly realizes that
it's just a con Wade ended up killing
the doctor and at this point he then
left Vanessa he'd also start to
reconsider the recruitment officer's
offer whereas they just have him looking
through leaplet and then meeting the
agent we then cut of the rain on the
Windows which is where he decides to go
to weapons plus and back at the bar he
gets handed a card with the agent's
phone number on which is the same as
Kevin space's character during American
Beauty he also looks like Kevin in
Spacey whose character sleeps with a
high schooler in there and this is why
he keeps calling him a n which yeah we
know what accusations came out a couple
of years later we also get a reference
to Jared from Subway right before he
kills him as well nice to see you Jared
and Deadpool calls some agent Smith
which actually a pretty good Easter egg
if you add the shades in the subtitles
he's called Agent Smith as well and at
the hour 335 Mark we see that Wade's
called him that on a Post-It note on the
wall at home he excuses and Nightmare is
dreaming that he kid leave Nissan's
daughter which is obviously a reference
to taken however there's a slightly
deeper cut here as Nissan starred in the
final Dirty Harry movie which is called
the Deadpool this is what gave Rob lield
the idea and it's where he got the name
from the character moving on we then C
back to the freeway where Wade really
lays into the X-Men the heavensgate
references to Marshall H Apple White
who's known for organizing the largest
mass Su side as part of his cult watched
the documentary on him last week and
yeah was involved Christ being an a and
the leaders saying they were aliens as
well I think got really weird but I
think it was them saying that it might
be how Charles is a mutant and so on and
so forth again sorry having to bleep all
this stuff as well YouTube's just a
nightmare at the moment for
demonetization with us they even gave us
a yellow dollar for showing vampires in
Blade 2 you know what I'm saying it's it
terrible the Colossus then says he's
going to take him to the professor with
Deadpool saying let us go talk to the
professor makavo or Stewart these
timelines are so conf confusing you get
that one mate you get it and he also
talks about 127 hours before soaring off
his arm he then jumps into a garbage
truck and we get another great
transition into the past this sees him
being wheeled into the lab which is
where they'll trigger his mutation you
also get a big nod to Green Lantern and
please don't make the super suit green
we're animated now it's also important
to know that chronologically the fourth
wall breakes only come after these
experiments in all the scenes where he's
normal I just keep him as a standard
character but after this is
talks to the audience down in the lab we
see the mutant marrow who has spikes
sticking out her back marrow is the
leader of the morocks and she possesses
bones that grow out of her skin here we
also meet Gina coro's angel dust who in
the comics also join the morocks her
powers in The Source material are based
on adrenaline which causes her to
quickly develop super strength however
this makes her Tire really easily which
is why she ends up becoming exhausted
when fighting against Colossus Y in Ajax
gave Deadpool his powers or as in the
comics it was caused by Dr kilbrew Ajax
was mainly his henchmen but they just
pushed the two characters together so
they could have one main villain for the
film at this point we see him getting
the serum and you can also notice drops
of blood within it the comics said
Wolverine's blood being used in the
experiments on Wade and this is what
gave the character's healing Factor it
saw that this could be how Wade gets it
here which ties it neatly to the end of
X-Men apocalypse that post credit scene
as his blood being taken which may
explain how the lab was able to get it
the blood was of course also used for
Logan with it being how they made x23
maybe I'm doing a bit too much for Fox
though here though cuz let's be honest
then Fox never cared about continuity
but I just try to draw stuff together
here a jaxson makes a joke about sewing
his mouth shut well sew your pretty
mouth shut which is of course a
reference to X-Men Origins Deadpool at
this point is tortur to trigger his
abilities but on this watch through I
wonder if it had already kicked in that
takes us
in now he of course as a healing Factor
and they mention how they keep putting
him through worse and worse pain to get
it to begin sorry guys I'm just moreon
and but I'll make myself laugh at least
even if no one else does but I actually
wondered if he was able to get through
this because he's constantly healing and
thus they have to then up things I
wonder if his skin change because his
blood cells were filled with oxygen and
then his body was trying to heal them
which is what then changed his
appearance you a few times a crap the
thought D the and it's completely
rubbish now we also meet the character
cunning with this being in odd to the
comics character David Cunningham in the
source material that's the character
worm who was also the one that gave
Deadpool his name he ended up dying
after Ajax pushed the experiments too
far and Wade snapped his neck as a sign
of mercy here he sets fire to the lab
and Cunningham looks at him almost like
he's thankful that he's finally out of
his misery just watching Wade get put in
that Suffocation machine it's genuinely
something that's always stuck with me
and I can't imagine how agonizing it
would be being stuck like this for days
normally they'd [__] foot around this
sort of stuff but here they really go
all in with it Ajax reveals that they're
actually making super slaves and that
he'll be fitted with a control color and
sold at the highest bidder these colors
appear at the 1H hour 7 Mark and I
wonder if the ones that appear in
Deadpool 2 are also related to it
fighting amongst the fire the scene
always reminded me a bit of Bea Vendetta
which we will cover on the channel at
some point but it it'll probably be
about November cuz that makes the most
sense I did just get the new Mondo 4K
steelbook though and yeah I'd love to do
that on a breakdown cuz it's absolutely
perfect for one now that film's origin
story had a phoenix metaphor 2 which
carries across here Wade who rises from
the fire seeing Vanessa he goes to
return to her but decides against her
after seeing people's reaction to him
now at this point they were going to get
some scenes riing off a groundhog day
and we'd see Deadpool constantly trying
to off himself he then keep waking up in
the morg and come to realize this
healing Factor made him near Invincible
there was a deleted scene of them
getting run over by a bus but they cut
this moment out and then skipped over
the Montage back at the bar they then
start brainstorming names including
scared devil which you get that we then
get Deadpool hunting down Francis and
can see from his photo on the wall that
he wears a crown of dicks wearing white
the blood becomes impossible to wash out
so in the end Wade starts rocking red
they also have a little nut to
Deathstroke in his very first costume
which we can see as just a single I slit
Deathstroke's real name is sled Wilson
with Deadpool borrowing heavily from the
character in the background we also hear
the Deadpool rap on the way you know
that all Chas every bad guy right in
their place which is building off the
back of the Deadpool game that had its
own WAP to it and Tim Muller got the
group back to record one for the
movie
call get for
days slowly he runs over someone on
Zamboni and we then cut to a drawing of
him which even has Zamboni guy written
on the Post-it note it's in this Montage
that we also meet blind Al with a
listening to Blind singer ra when we cut
to her apartment later on Deadpool says
and also um there's about 116 kilos of
cocaine buried somewhere in the
apartment right next to the cure for
blindness and cut to Deadpool 2 and I
love how we get a call back to this as
we can see both the drugs in cure for
blindness hidden under the floorboards
just behind them we can also see a
finger statue a which is actually the
flying fickle finger of fate award this
was presented on laughing which is where
it was given for the most ridiculous
news item of the week now when Wade gets
back to his apartment we see covers his
severed hand with a red towel at the
hour six Mark he swaps us out for a
clean one which we can see is cream
colored this shows how this other towels
red because of blood showing that he's
used it a lot before slowly his hands
starting to grow back and the VFX artist
looked at fetuses to see how they formed
in the W inside the apartment he picks
up a unicorn and a bottle of lotion
which we kind of know what he's up to
cuz we caught him in the fast forward
section at roughly the hour and 4 minute
Mark cut away then going to the strip
club which is where we get our Stanley
Cameo Stan jokingly said he was annoyed
they didn't let him film at a real one
with a scene being done on a Clos set
this was s spliced up and then dropped
into it and from here we see as Ajax
kidnaps Vanessa realizing she's gone
then leads to weasel saying go get her
tiger this is of course a notd to Mary
Jane who constantly says things along
the same lines to Peter Parker Deadpool
also says it later on to Nega
Sonic which takes us into the quote
unquote hel carry out with Deadpool and
Cole walking out to DMX X going give it
here carries a double meaning as X could
mean the X-Men and they all possess the
X Gene the scrapyard itself has several
x's in it with there being three signs
for the company amix we can also catch
four crossing signs which are all
carrying an X and on top of this after
the superhero Landing we see that angel
dust back has straps on it that make an
X now from here negga Sonic Burns
through her clothing to reveal her X-Men
super low it this is pulled straight out
the comics and it reminded me a lot of
the ones from the grant Morrison run Mel
are apparently for to get this in the
movie as Fox was still wanting to go
with those black leather suits what
would you prefer yellow
spandex Yes
actually I love this action scene with
the superhero Landings I'm spelling out
Francis and also using Nega Sonic to
push him up to the Hy carrier leads to a
big fight and at this point Deadpool
battles Francis while Vanessa is put in
the Suffocation machine on the ground
negasonic and Colossus take out angel
dust and after causing the carrier to
crash Deadpool kills Francis what I love
is that this is where the gunny got from
blind Al which in that scene he almost
didn't take we then see Colossus start
vomiting and this was apparently a
nightmare for motion capture Greg Lal as
he had to keep retching over and over
and over again Miller said he had to
step in and tell him to stop because he
was wretching so much he was going to
pass out Deadpool end says now if you'll
excuse me I'm just a boy about to stand
in front of a girl which is a play on
nodding hell I'm also just a girl
standing in front of a boy he then takes
off his mask and we can see it's got
hugman's face cut out from the cover of
the sexiest man alive magazine ending
the movie to Careless Whisper we then
jump to the post credit scene ripping
off the back of Ferris buer he comes out
wearing the bathrobe and even makes his
sound this is from the song oh yeah by
the ban yellow which featured in one of
the most famous scenes in the movie
Deadpool also says cable will be in the
sequel which as we know came true with
Josh Brolin lastly he says were you
expecting Sam Jackson to show up which
calls back to the post credit scene that
arguably started the whole craze anyway
that wraps up the movie and it went on
to have great success great success this
is the first R-rated film to have a
3-day opening of over $100 million which
led the way to it later grossing 782
million Reynolds really helped with the
marketing and he got involved in every
way he could help to push the film
behind the scenes though he was doing
what he could to help out the fans and
there's a really sad story with a kid
called Conor McGrath McGrath was a
13-year-old with cancer who asked to
attend one of the screenings as part of
make a wish these were held in New York
and LA with the events being fan
exclusives unfortunately his illness got
worse and McGrath was enabl to travel
out from Edmonton hearing this Reynolds
traveled out to him and they held a
private screening with him sadly Connor
passed away not long after but I can
imagine this really made those dark
times have a bit of light to them
hopefully you've also enjoyed this
breakdown and look I'm not saying what
as nice as that obviously mate but uh
it's hard to seg away from something so
kind but I hope you've had a good time
watching this and huge thank you for all
you guys support may have also seen that
we're putting out some Community posts
where we talk about all the big content
that we're now dropping for members
we're sort of Shifting over doing older
film so there's not a big rush to get
videos out day one and because of that
we're dropping stuff earlier for members
which means you can get to see all our
classic movie breakdowns before anybody
else it's a sort of give what you can
thing where we're just asking for 99
cents a month if you want to donate and
for that you'll get early access to all
our audio versions and then the fully
edited ones once they release that's
just 1188 a year and it makes a huge
difference to the channel and just helps
us out so much thank you from the bottom
of my heart to everyone who's already
doing it and we'll of course be back
with Deadpool 2 very soon also in the
middle of doing the Wicker man so keep
an eye out for that on the channel but
we're having a bit of copyright issues
with Studio Canal so hopefully it won't
be too long you want something else to
watch there's also a big breakdown on
the screen right now so head over there
right after this but out the way huge
thank you for watching this I've been
Paul you've been the best I'll see you
next time take care peace